jeanne moreau bonsoir vous aviez déjà
chanté notamment le fameux tourbillon la
chanson du gym beaucoup d'autres
chansons d'ailleurs jacques canetti
vient de paraître peut faire paraître un
nouveau cd avec en tout et tout de même
60 46 chanson c'est tout votre oeuvre
j'aime toujours vous avez eu plein
d'honneur le grand prix du disque le
grand prix de l'académie charles cros là
c'est la première fois sauf erreur que
vous jouez la récitante dans ce dans
cette oeuvre et vous raconter que
raconter barça vous a plutôt perturbée
voire paniqués
c'est à dire que je me trouvais si près
d'un grands concertistes est de
participer d'une façon si intime
ça m'a beaucoup impressionné oui parce
que la chanson c'est pas pareil je pense
était plus bâbord qui vous a posé
problème les autres oeuvres dos aux cdc
plus vos craintes de tassement des
divertissements ou et d'erik satie
mais oui ben c'est d'abord ça a déjà été
fait et puis j'ai imaginé des amis à moi
et qui ont des enfants adorables et je
leur ai raconté l'histoire voilà alors
si on en croit la rumeur le pianiste
jean marc luisada qu'on a aperçu tout à
l'heure vous a dit ça serait bien que
vous soyez cette voix souffle et d'erik
satie parce qu'il est fou ce mec il est
dingue il est givrée
il partageait ce jugement musicale vrai
oui c'est vrai que c'était un type givry
c'est un homme qui a cogné cocteau qui a
travaillé pendant une époque
merveilleuse qui a fait des musiques
pour parade pour des ballets même des
films et c'est une oeuvre tout à fait
particulière si vous deviez vivre une
autre vie ce serait se serait dont la
musique
j'aimerais j'aimerais être très près de
la musique instrumentistes quelques
instruments enfin je ne sais pas ça
serait le grand mystère
vous avez vu que tu musicale ou sujet
simplement étudié le solfège qu'un pas
ce que je faisais partie d'une chorale à
l'école quand on fait de la danse ou
s'intéressent à la musique dans une
deuxième vie on vous retrouvera et faire
derrière je m'en serve aux autres
alors nous avons invité également ce
soir c'est un plaisir parce que viennent
de paraître de très très beaux ouvrages
qui vous sont consacrés tout d'abord
chez ramsay cinéma grâce à jean claude
marrot une remise à jour de votre
filmographie avec beaucoup beaucoup de
photos qui disent le temps qui passe
le tout pour 395 front et puis aux
éditions norma aussi un gros livre un
beau livre jeanne moreau portrait d'une
femme signé michael del mar 2 169 francs
je vous pose de voir tout de suite
qu'elle fait vous chantiez c'est quand
vous feuilletez ses albums c'est quoi
c'est la nostalgie vous aimez vous ne
s'est pas dit il installe g c'est tout
toutes les choses qui ont été faites
tous les gens rencontrés c'est là le
miroitement d'une vie voilà c'est
incroyable moi qui crois que je fais peu
de choses
c'est c'est énorme à propos de
miroitements d'une vie je prends vous
aviez l'intention d'écrire un livre qui
serait pas vraiment une autobiographie
mais ça y ressemble mais tout de même un
petit peu en un an ça j'ai créé sur
l'allemand et adama qui commence par la
lettre a uniquement il alors vous avez à
propos de biographies y en a une qui va
par et bientôt en angleterre et vous dit
en avoir lu quelques lignes ça vous a
passablement épouvanté oui il y en a une
autre qui se prêtent pas pour l'amérique
à l'arrêt sera peut-être mieux pourquoi
parce que des mauvaises ou parce que
vous n'avez pas envie qu'on raconte
votre vie pas qu'elle ne s'accapare
votre vie en emmenant scène les contacts
qu'ils n'ont pas été très très
harmonieux lorsque j'ai rencontré cette
jeune femme et c'est tout à fait
subjectif jamais empêché personne
décrire votre dernier rôle à l'écran
c'est donc catherine de russie vous
jouez le rôle de la peyrie trice
elisabeth cela ne paiera trice paillard
d'audit vous assez paillardes est assez
autoritaire en effet mais ça c'est un
film américain le prochain film c'est
avec ismaël match est le printemps
ok merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir dont je rappelle
la sortie donc l'histoire de babar entre
autres avec jeanne moreau et jean marc
luisada